-Trump wore a mask publicly
for the first time.
It seems like a lot of guys are
having a hard time wearing masks
because they feel like
it makes them look weak.
Well, I saw a commercial
that will help those guys out.
Check it out.
-Are you a big strong man
worried wearing a face mask
will make you look like
a little girl in pigtails?!
Well, worry no more!
Hi. I'm Lee Durango, the owner
of Masculine Man Masks,
the number-one mask store
for tough guys
and badass men, as well!
My masks have all sorts
of manly designs...
like Predator fangs..
a barbed-wire fence
around an ATV dealership...
and a Rottweiler shredding
on an electric guitar!
-[ Electric guitar whines ]
-My masks will make you feel
like a beef-eating man,
not a pretty little princess
in her castle
singing to her cartoon birds!
But what if you wanna look like
you're not wearing a mask
at all?!
Well, I got you, brother!
I also sell masks that look like
the bottom part of your mouth.
And let's just say there's
some pretty tough-guy stuff
going on with
that mouth of yours!
Like holding a toothpick...
those chin piercings
the lead singers
of '90s new-metal bands had...
and lips stained with
award-winning barbecue sauce
from scorching-hot ribs
that you ate over the sink!
My prices at Masculine Man Masks
blow the competitors
out of the water!
And just look
at the kind of junk
those wimps are selling
over at Macho Mouth Mufflers.
Abs on your chest,
not your face!
T-This is so confusing.
That's why we sell masks...
-With a jacked mouth!
-So come on
to Masculine Man Masks.
Because covering
the bottom half of your face
doesn't have to make you
look like a big sissy
with a shellfish allergy!
-Masculine Man Masks
is located next to
Charlie's Chain Wallet Emporium
and Burly Biff's
Bacon Barn and Bait Box
in the city's
Disturbing Dude District.
♪♪
-Oh, my goodness.
I -- I want one of those.
Those jacked --
Those jacked mouths.
[ Laughter ]